they were killed while trying to save
lives the polio workers were gunned down
in their van as they set out to
administer vaccinations door-to-door in
quetta western pakistan
visiting the scene regional interior
minister akbar durrani described the
shooting
this morning terrorists on motorbikes
opened fire on the polio workers vehicle
as a result four workers were killed and
three others wounded
although the attacks succeeded we are
hopeful that our law enforcement agency
will be able to bring the perpetrators
to justice
this is just the latest in a series of
attacks on polio workers in pakistan
there was no immediate claim of
responsibility
but taliban militants have claimed in
the past that polio teams are spies of
the west or that the vaccine causes
infertility the attack was the most
deadly to be carried out on health
workers in pakistan for at least two
years
polio's not been eradicated but our
people are getting killed why is this
cruelty being inflicted upon us
polio is a highly contagious disease
that can kill or [ __ ] children within
hours
vaccination campaigns have wiped it out
in most of the world
but in pakistan the disease continues to
spread